we are defining a random variable is a
real-valued function on the sample space
so this is a good occasion to make sure
that we understand what the function is
to define a function we start with two
sets one set call it a is the domain of
the function and we have our second set
then a function is a rule that for any
element of a Associates an element of B
and we use a notation of this kind to
indicate that we are dealing with a
function f that map's elements of a into
elements of B now two elements of a may
be mapped to the same element of B this
is allowed what is important however is
that every element of a is mapped to
exactly one element of B not more but it
is also possible that we have some
elements of B that do not correspond to
any of the elements of a now I said that
a function is a rule that assigns points
of a to points in B but what exactly do
we mean by a rule if we want to be more
precise a function would be defined as
follows it would be defined as a set of
pairs of values it would be a set of
pairs of the form X Y such that X is
always an element of a Y is always an
element of B and also most important
each X in a appears in exactly one pair
so this would be a formal definition of
what the function is it is a collection
of ordered pairs of this kind as a
concrete example let us start with the
set consisting of these elements here
and let B be the set of real numbers and
consider the function that corresponds
to what we usually call the square so
it's a function that squares its
argument then this function would be
represented by the following collection
of pairs so this is the value of X and
this is the corresponding value of y any
particular X shows up just once in this
collection of pairs but a certain why
for example y equal to 1 shows up twice
because minus 1 and plus 1 both map to
the same element of B now this is a
representation in terms of of ordered
pairs but we could also think of the
function as being described by a table
we could for instance put this
information here in a form of a table of
this kind and say that this table
describes the function for any element X
it tells us what the corresponding
element Y is however when the set a is
an infinite set it is not clear what we
might mean by saying a table an infinite
table whereas this definition in terms
of ordered pairs still applies for
example if you are interested in the
function which is again the square
function from the real numbers the way
you would specify that function
abstractly would be as follows
you could write it's the set of all
pairs of this form
such that X is a real number and now
such pairs of course belong to the
two-dimensional plane because it's a
pair of numbers so this set here can be
viewed as a formal definition or
specification of the squaring function
now what this set is is something that
we can actually plot if we go on the
two-dimensional plane the points of this
form are exactly the points that belong
to the graph of the square function so
this abstract definition really all that
it says is that a function is the same
thing as the plot of that function but
it's important here to make a
distinction the function is the entire
plot so this set here is the function f
whereas if I tell you a specific number
X the corresponding value here would be
f of X so here X is a number and f of X
is also a number and those two values X
and f of X define this particular point
on this plot but the function itself is
the entire plot let us also take this
occasion to talk a little bit about the
notation and the proper way of talking
about functions here is the most common
way that one would describe a function
and this is an appropriate way we have
described the domain we've described the
set on which the function takes values
and I'm telling you for any X in that
set what the value of the function is on
the other hand sometimes people use a
more loose language such as for example
they would say the function X square
what does that mean well what this means
is exactly this statement now let us
consider this function the function f
again from the reals to the reals that's
defined by f of Z equals to Z squared is
this a different function
or is the same function it's actually
the same function because these two
involve the same sets and they produce
their outputs the values of F using
exactly the same rule they take an
argument in the de square that argument
now if you were to use informal notation
you would be referring to that second
function as the function Z squared and
now if you use informal language it's
less clear that the function x square
and the function Z square are one at the
same thing whereas with this terminology
here it would be pretty clear that we're
talking about the same function finally
suppose that we have already defined the
function how should we refer to it in
general should we call it the function f
or should we say the function f of X
well when X is a number f of X is also a
number so f of X is not really a
function the appropriate language is
this one we talk about the function f
although quite often people will abuse
language and they will use this
terminology but it's important to keep
in mind what we really mean the idea is
that we need to think of a function as
some kind of box or even a computer
program if you wish that takes inputs
and produces outputs and there's a
distinction between F which is the box
from the value F of X that the function
takes if we feed it with a specific
argument